das politische Gesicht der Ukraine das
ist natürlich ganz klar er wurde mir
selenski ein Präsident der für die
Freiheit seines Landes kämpft und gegen
putinstag tägliche Angriffe na er hält
das Land zusammen er motiviert die
Menschen und sendet Botschaften in die
Welt aber die Seele der Ukraine ist eine
andere die Seele des Landes das ist
Olena selenska sie ist die Frau neben wo
Leute mir selensky natürlich seine
Stütze und diese Frau hat Bild viel zu
Paul ronsheimer exklusiv interviewt wir
haben eben schon einen kleinen
Ausschnitt aus diesem Interview gesehen
es war ein wirklich bewegendes Gespräch
über
Ängste und Hoffnungen
sie ist die First Lady der Ukraine Olena
selenska die gute Seele in diesem
powerkuppel sie ist die Frau die dem
Präsidenten die nötige Kraft gibt sie
steht ihrem Mann zur Seite bedingungslos
seit über 25 Jahren
Olena selenska ist seit den 90er Jahren
mit volodemia selensky liiert gefunkt
hatte es zwischen den Teenagern in der
Schulzeit
1995 kamen sie zusammen da waren der
Präsident und die First Lady gerade
einmal 17 Jahre alt
2003 heiratete das Paar doch jetzt im
Krieg hat sich auch für das Traumpaar
einiges geändert
wir arbeiten wie viele Familien in der
Ukraine die meisten Familien sind
getrennt im Alltag können wir uns nicht
oft sehen
natürlich kann ich ihn ab und zu hier im
Büro treffen das kann ich leider nicht
von unseren Kindern sagen sie treffen
ihn nur selten und er fehlt den Kindern
sehr wenn wir über Gefühle sprechen dann
denke ich dass es gerade viel zu
verarbeiten gibt und ich denke wir
brauchen einander noch mehr
[Musik]
in dieser entscheidenden Phase ist die
Rolle der First Lady nicht mehr nur
hintergründig oder schmückend sie ist in
die Öffentlichkeit getreten um zu dem
Gesicht ihres Landes zu werden dem
Gesicht einer Frau einer Mutter eines
einfühlsamen Menschen First Lady zu sein
war nieselens gastraumrolle aber wie so
viele ihrer ukrainischen Landsleute in
diesem Krieg hat sich silenska der
Situation mit Entschlossenheit gestellt
es ist auch mein Traum den die Besatzer
zerstört haben
sie betont immer dass sie als Mutter und
Tochter und nicht nur als First Lady
spricht sie ist eine gefühlvollere
Version ihres Mannes und verkündet stets
dass es im Krieg in der Ukraine um mehr
als die Ukraine geht es geht darum wer
die Werte des Westens aufrechterhalten
wird
Olena glänzt als Leuchtfeuer für ihr
Volk und Akteuren im Kampf um die Herzen
und Köpfe der Ukraine
Olena glänzt als Leuchtfeuer für ihr
Volk und Akteuren im Kampf um die Herzen
und Köpfe der Ukraine ihre Reden
verdeutlichen silenzga Stil eine
knallharte Botschaft in einem sanften
Gewand
[Musik]
wir haben keine Zeit mehr Angst zu haben
noch am Anfang hatten wir Angst dass der
Angreifer wütend wird oder dass wir ihn
verärgern aber jetzt kann es nicht mehr
schlimmer werden es gibt keinen Grund
mehr Angst zu haben
es ist die Liebe für ihr Heimatland und
die Hoffnung dass irgendwann alles gut
werden kann die Olena und volodimir
durch diese dunklen Tage tragen
[Musik]